pas de chrono range ni de circulation
sur le chemin de la côte saint antoine
en 1840
quand la maison goode a été construite
c'était la campagne
il ne reste plus que deux maisons de
cette époque l'une fidèle à son passé
l'autre transformer ce qu'on voit ici
effectivement les terrains des quatre
maisons parce qu'il y en avait quatre
maisons qui y comprenez le maître
kafteur avec des vergers et potagers la
vidéo de l'agencé chargée de vendre la
maison good d'une valeur de 2 millions
de dollars met en évidence les arbres
centenaires les jardins et l'intérieur
de la maison
plusieurs éléments ont été préservés
trois générations se sont succédé et
dans la famille il ya personne que
modifier l'intérieur
la maison est intacte on a une comme un
cliché de ce qu'était la façon de vivre
à l'époque la maison est restée dans la
famille pendant 150 ans elle est déjà
reconnue pour sa valeur architecturale
par la municipalité de wesley c'était en
2002 scor la loi culturel a été changé
pour que les municipalités puissent
protéger les intérieurs mais c'est très
très rarement monsieur god était très
fier de sa maison et ce sera la première
maison est cité
intérieure au québec pour protéger la
maison good son intérieur mais aussi
l'ensemble du paysage
la ville a émis un avis de motion le 6
juillet qui donnera lieu à une séance
publique en septembre puis à un
règlement qui imposerait certaines
contraintes aux nouveaux propriétaires
on connaît que ce n'est pas un musée non
plus et on va travailler avec le nouveau
propriétaire pour le rendre comme une
maison assez moderne comme vivre dedans
mais en même temps préserver les
éléments importants pour la conseillère
l'eau l'âme
ce sont des mesures exceptionnelles pour
une maison exceptionnel ici anne louise
despatie radio canada montréal